People often ask me how I got the scar on my arm.
And what happened was, when I was 14 years old,
I got really sick and no one could figure out what was wrong with me.
I was very ill and finally, after a week of not getting better,
my mother took me to the hospital and I, after many tests,
was finally, days and days later, diagnosed with a hyper allergy,
something called Stevens-Johnson syndrome.
And once they finally found out what was wrong with me,
they treated me for it, but not before I had spent weeks in the hospital,
weeks blind and mute, as well as being fed by tubes
and having to sleep sitting up so that I wouldn't choke on my own saliva.
My mother, in her fashion, moved in to the hospital to be by my bedside
and slept every night in the hospital to take care of me
and she wouldn't leave my side.
And finally, when I was released on February 1st,
I remember it was a Friday, as we were riding home in our car,
she said, I've made a promise to God that if God delivers you safely
out of the hospital that I would go and I would do a penance
and I would go to the temple and make an offering to give thanks
for delivering my child home safely.
So I know you're really sick, but I'm going to see if your stepdad
can drive us on Sunday to the temple.
And I just sort of nodded in my very ill way and I said okay.
And on that Sunday, February 3rd, my stepfather and my mother and I
drove in our red Ford Mercury car with the black interior
to the Hindu temple and I was very ill.
I was very, very weak and frail.
And that was long enough ago, I was 14, a long time ago,
when they still had the front seat that was a couch seat.
So my mother wedged me in between her and my stepdad
because she wanted to take care of me.
I was still really sick.
I could barely hold my head up.
I had lost a lot of weight.
I was so weak that she said, you stay in the car, I'll do the offering.
She went, she did the prayers, she did the flowers, she rang the bell,
she got the food and they came back in the car
and she handed me this squeaky round styrofoam plate
with a bunch of yellow rice on it and some vegetable curry or whatever it was.
And off we went back down the highway
and I remember thinking what a beautiful sunny Sunday it was.
And I was trying desperately to concentrate on this plate of food
and my mother said, you know, just try and have a couple bites of it.
Just, you know, it's blessed, it's from the puja we did.
And as I was eating this rice, suddenly I heard a loud bang!
And I looked up and I can remember the plate flying
and yellow rice everywhere like confetti.
And as the rice came down, all I could see
was this beautiful blue sky, this crystal clear blue sky.
No clouds, no cars, no road in front of us,
no trees, nothing, just endless miraculous blue sky
and these kind of yellow grains flying all around.
Then all of a sudden I heard another thud
and then I kind of heard...
And it was us, we were flying and then we were airborne, I realized.
And then what stopped our fall was this tree
and then we kind of went down further down this embankment
and then finally came to a last thud
and there was just stillness.
I kind of strained my neck and I could see my mother to my right
and we were all pinned very closely together
and my mother had her eyes closed and her mouth open
and blood was trickling out of the side of her mouth.
And to my left, my stepfather was saying over and over again
this mantra of, where are we Vijay?
What happened Vijay? Weren't we driving Vijay?
We were at the temple Vijay, Vijay, Vijay, my mother.
And from my mother emanated this profound and nauseating silence.
And I started to scream at my mother.
I started to say, Mom, are you awake? Are you awake?
If you're awake, say something, say something, please.
If you're not awake, I love you, Mommy, I love you.
If you are awake, I love you, but please say something.
And in the back of me screaming was this chorus,
this non-stop loop of my stepfather,
almost like that cliche image or track that the cartoons
when a bird or a cartoon character is hit on the head
and they say, where am I? What's going on?
That was exactly what he was doing.
And he just kept repeating this.
And it was all of a sudden I started feeling things.
I started feeling hot and cold and wet and sticky and itchy
and burning and all I could feel from my mother
was this silence emanating from her
that kept getting louder and louder, this silence.
Then I finally heard a man call down to us and say,
are you okay? Are you okay?
I said, yes, we're alive, we're alive.
Please get help. Please, please get help.
And then a bunch of firemen came.
And I remember hearing the crunch of their boots
down the leaves, on the leaves, down the embankment.
And they came and they kind of got, I heard chainsaws.
I heard a helicopter in the distance approaching.
I heard blow torches.
I would later learn that they had to use these famous things
called the jaws of life to cut open the roof
of this red Ford Mercury Zephyr.
And so I got taken to the City of Angels
and my parents got taken somewhere else.
My arm, because we were pinned so tight,
my arm had flown across my mother's chest.
And so my arm was just shattered in many pieces.
And I lay there for hours and hours,
not knowing what happened to my parents,
not knowing if my parents were okay, if my mother was alive.
And I remember being incredibly uncomfortable
in a cold hospital bed with glass everywhere,
in every crevice of my body, under my nails, in my hair,
in my ears, just shattered glass everywhere.
And I remember, you know, in the emergency room,
I remember vague bits and pieces of what people said,
like, you know, well, I don't think it's worth doing,
but, you know, I questioned the mobility of that arm
or, well, let's leave it alone.
And we were home. It took us a long time to heal.
My stepfather broke his leg,
his left leg in four places, his hip in two.
My mother had to come home
and still have a hospital bed at home for weeks and months.
And we had one-to-one nursing,
24 hours around the clock at home,
because, of course, my mother this time could not care for me,
could not be by my side.
Indeed, she had her own hospital bed.
But my mother was determined.
They said that they weren't going to do any surgery on my arm
because they thought it wasn't really worth it,
that it would probably be dormant,
be kind of semi-lame at my side.
And, you know, I was so young,
I could learn to do everything with my left hand.
And so my mother was determined not to let this happen.
And so she, from her hospital bed at home,
ordered me to go to another orthopedist
whom she had found on the phone through colleagues,
and he said, well, she's so young, we should do it.
And he decided to do surgery on my arm,
and I got this very beautiful, thin scratch of a surgery incision,
and there was a cylindrical metal plate that was put on.
And as my arm got better, the scar got worse.
And, you know, I was very awkward to begin with,
and I was 14, I had all these hormones and feeling off about my body,
and I knew that the scar on my forearm was looking bad,
and so I knew what was to come with this scar.
And so, anyway, years go by,
and I had to have multiple surgeries on the arm
every time the arm got more and more better,
every time the scar got longer and thicker and ropier and darker.
And, you know, I kind of found ways to look normal while hiding it, you know.
And I would go on dates in college,
and I would have to really think about
whether I was going to wear a short-sleeve blouse or a long-sleeve blouse.
And then I was studying abroad, and I started modeling, of all things.
And, you know, I wasn't a fancy model.
I used it, I graduated from college,
and then I really started modeling to pay off my college loans.
I was a fit model, a workaday model.
And then this weird thing happened,
and the agency called me and they said,
guess what, Helmut Newton wants to shoot you.
And, you know, I was young, and I was like, who's Helmut Newton?
They said, you know, Helmut Newton, the guy, and he's great.
He does these beautiful, sexy, dangerous, edgy pictures of women,
and he wants to shoot you.
So, you know, before my agency would, you know,
when they were calling around, so they'd get comments like,
you know, yeah, she's kind of pretty, but that scar.
Those same people were calling, going,
can we book the girl with the scar?
It's amazing that somebody else, thinking you're cool,
can make you think differently of yourself.
And, you know, so all of a sudden I was doing all these runway shows,
you know, I was like doing Alberta Freddie and Herve Leger,
and all these great, and so my salary went up,
and, you know, all of a sudden I was the girl with the scar.
So, you know, maybe the scar was this mixed blessing in a way, right?
Because it paid off my college loans, and, you know,
bought me an apartment, paid off my mom's mortgage,
a lot of cool things, so I thought that was great.
And I was thinking about all of this recently
because I found myself on my back in another hospital bed
staring at another white ceiling.
And I was told that I would probably never have children naturally,
and that was very upsetting, as many women can understand, and men too.
And then I got pregnant, which was a real surprise, but a happy one.
And then I was told it would be a difficult pregnancy,
and then it was a really difficult pregnancy,
and I was ordered on complete bed rest the last trimester of my pregnancy.
And my mother, in true fashion, moved in with me the next day.
Yeah, it's true.
And, you know, when your mother moves in with you at 39,
it's a completely different experience.
But there she was, valiant in her nurturing,
and, you know, it was a very scary last few weeks of the pregnancy.
I wound up going to the hospital more than once before I had the baby,
and one time for five days with a fetal heart monitor and tubes everywhere
and staring at the ceiling and thinking to myself,
God, please get me out of here.
Please deliver me and my child intact and healthy out of this hospital.
I recently miraculously found myself again with my mother in another car,
this time going to Flushing Queens to another temple,
but this time to give thanks for the safety and delivery of my daughter.
Thank you.